[Music]
Alright, let's go, what's going on,
who is he?
Applause]
[Music]
Face
[Applause]
Let's do the best evil I
'm sadder than anyone else That role that can kill
Shikoku
changes even at the end of the
bow
Everyone in the world
takes hold of the past Days when I dreamed of escaping someday
At that time, I was confused by the sky
[Music]
Let me reassure
you, you won't cut
The so-called miracle resides in
this princess. She
was a special princess who never took a night out even though she was a
princess
.
Well, it's probably because the lanterns aren't lit.  Are you visiting me? That's
why I'm here
Woo-hee is different from other miracles
Even if you see disaster,
you'll believe the rumors, too
.
Chicken,
shall we close
this? This is a precious crystal.
[Music]
Suicide
Kito
Looking for a fake
If you ask me, I'll accept anything
I hear that's your role I
won't accept a request that can't be paid in return
If it's a prayer, it's
an asset.It looks like there's a lot of people looking for lost items
.
Either way, it's
not a good thing No one says it
's a preliminaries for immortality
or courage,
but you're a human, right?
What a
verse 10, verse 10
It's good I won't listen to your request Hurry up and say goodbye I forgot something Here
you go
Tar-chan
Who is the person who smells good
To the summer of the shrine maiden who served the goddess Guren Nyan Nyan
Music] The
emperors, who were devoted to the wonders of their weapons,
To monopolize their power,
they
enshrined them in high esteem, and gave them a special miraculous rank.  Do I have to ask you for a
favor? No one can order Ufi It
seems I've offended
Luffy
[music]
You never listen to me
How many times have you come?  I won't listen to your requests
I brought you a gift You
don't need a fancy hair ornament to lure someone with something like that Hurry up and take
it home
What is that?
It's
freshly made
I heard it's your favorite food Can
you listen to me?
I
don't
have a camera I
don't have enough hair to look for people from things
If you know, go home and
ask for this  It seems that
courage is possessed by this.
What is
it that you saw courage only
once?  I just want
to
know if the requirement is enough for the emperor to come on a business trip.
So what do you think Mama
You're not feeling well with the free food, aren't you
?
]
[music]
[applause]
I can't speak
with this It seems like it was a hihin
That wrist mark
Three stars It's from the current dynasty
That courage is my grandfather or my father's high-ranking concubine
I'm haunted by this because I was strangled, or because I died an unfortunate death
.
It is said that
if a person dies, he or
she can go to Rakdo across the sea.
Won't you take it off? Why do you break your heart with that
courage?
I wonder if I should destroy your store
.
And I
don't care if I can take care of myself. I'll give you a break today.
Thank you very much.
Did you come all the way here to say an unreasonable demand?
I've never met someone who works for the palace. No, I
didn't hear there was a rescue over there yesterday
, but I don't think there's
any.
Rumors say you're really 16 years old.
10 verses have a strange way of
speaking, don't they
?  Have you been here since the time of the current emperor
?
You're the current Empress Dowager, you're imprisoned. If you
don't know about imprisonment, you don't even know that your current ally was defeated and died
.  Music]
Mother of the Crown Prince
But the emperor didn't give up and gathered up his strength to
rise up.
He was a beautiful person.
That's why I heard that the emperor had a beautiful appearance,
but
he was a dull man.
There was a miracle that the expert was found out and executed, and there was also
a miracle that he was
poisoned.
She was of a low rank, but she was a
fleeting beauty. The
half-princess
lived in the palace of the three princesses, but the
mountain princess was young and beautiful, and
she was the daughter
of Oela.  Well, one day, the
size of
it died from the poison that was in the thick
cloth She was pregnant, and when I
scrutinized it rigorously, I found a reading from the quality of Princess Han's room
[music]
Fan that night  The princess died by hanging Put
your criticism on the upholstery of the room
[Music]
Did you wear earrings?
It's a high-class place, so
this place is also spacious. Did you
really kill the Empress of 3
?
Even when
he was raped, ostensibly a maid was framed as a criminal and
executed
.
I can't help it. We can't leave here for the rest of our lives
, so what is the facility investigating?
I'm just curious about
a certain courage.
It's a sad thing. Come
to think of it, I've heard stories like this, the
current emperor's grandfather
.
Courage will appear then Courage of
the royal family of all dynasties
Gardens have exterminated
the Lan family of all dynasties
Old men,
women and even little babies, indiscriminate
Courage
Shaking off the beautiful silver hair that is the mark of the Minami family,
I keep spitting out curse words
.
[MUSIC]
Uffi shouldn't want anything
How's the low base
going?
The
amount of
property you have acquired does not match the estimated amount.I will continue to investigate whether the movement of the eunuch is necessary to find the empress dowager's hidden property
.
No,
it's the woman who tricked the selection and drove Tarcher to a wandering death
What are you trying to say?
If it's Tacha now, it's to create a crime like that
and execute it Then, I won't follow the
same rut as that woman Iwonder what
's next
It seems
that company expenses are
too much for me.
Don't come here anymore, right? There's a lot to do at the Crown Prince's
Palace.
What a
dreadful
mother, the reason why you didn't resist was
because she was afraid of harming you.
I'll find the perfect reason I'll
jump my head after
retreating with it Don't worry, it's just a little bit more I won't forgive
that woman who brutally killed my mother